the next aggressive opening we're going
to be looking at is the Halloween Gambit
it is extremely risky but it is so much
fun to play and the Halloween's Gambit
is night taking here on E5 which seems a
little crazy and it is which is why it
makes the video uh Knight ticking here
on E5 the Pawn's gonna push forward to a
D4 if the Knight comes back here to C6
we kind of just push forward again we
can kind of force it to come back here
so very aggressive just continuously
pushing forcing black to really just
move his Knights across the board he
could try another night move but all in
all Weiss is going to be pushing forward
with his pawns trying to control the
center get his Bishop involved his Queen
has some support right here definitely a
fun opening and although White's down
the material many times if black doesn't
play perfectly white can get that back